- [Voiceover] Fragrant pine trees,
snowy streets, spacious log cabins.
It's the quintessential mountain town.
Welcome to Jackson Hole, China.
Yeah that's right, China.
The town has over 1,500 homes.
Most residents use this
place as a weekend getaway
from the hustle and bustle of Beijing.
But there's another reason they come here:
a shared passion for the American West.
- My name is Sonjunie.
I'm from Beijing, China.
- [Voiceover] He's lived
here for seven years
and has fully embraced the
lifestyle of the town.
- I like American film.
Especially Western film.
Yes, John Wayne.
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] There's no ski
resort in Jackson Hole, China,
but they do have a church
which looks straight out
of A Little House on the
Prairie, a Disney store,
and a whole lot of
American-style suburban sprawl.
- Many American people
come here and think:
“Woah, it's a wild place!”
- [Voiceover] It's a slice of Americana
and only two hours Northwest of Beijing.